[Music]
the Joint Task Force two or jtf2 is a
special operations unit of the Canadian
Armed Forces considered a superior unit
they're an extremely prepared and
precise spec ops unit they exist to
protect Canada's interests both at home
and abroad by eliminating terrorism and
national threats will though primarily
tasked to counterterrorism operations
they also specialize in direct actions
such as reconnaissance hostage recovery
and private security detail in 1992 is a
response to the recommendations that the
Royal Canadian Mounted Police is special
Emergency Response Team be disbanded a
new military counterterrorism unit was
established the Canadian military forces
had a much larger recruit pool to work
with and the general population were not
all that happy with having law
enforcement officers using lethal means
as a first resource in 1993 the first
100 members were recruited comprising of
the now disbanded Canadian airborne
regiment and also princess Patricia's
Canadian light infantry the jtf2 are
known for the discretion and
professionalism during operations they
are the quiet professionals aspiring for
excellence working cohesively as a
single unit they have a reputation for
completing missions with accuracy and
precision the jtf2 are closely allied
with the very best Special Operations
Forces worldwide
allowing them to operate seamlessly when
called upon after the events of the
September 11 attacks the unit was
committed to the International Special
Operations Forces coalition in
Afghanistan this was the first time that
the jtf2 was used in a major combat role
outside of Canada after the reactivation
of Team rainbow in 2015 two Joint Task
Force two operators were recruited to
bring their skills and expertise to
assist in the fight against terrorism on
a global scale
these operators were named Frost and
Buck
[Music]
[Music]
you
ready for company deploying welcome
[Music]
Tina Ling sang codenamed Frost is a
defending operator and team rainbow
frost was born and raised in Vancouver
British Columbia on her 18th birthday
she enlisted with the Royal Canadian Air
Force she graduated top of her class at
the Royal Military College of Canada and
upon completion of a mechanical
engineering degree and officers training
Frost was stationed on Canada's west
coast with a joint Rescue Coordination
centre Victoria from there she served on
the primary search and rescue response
team covering British Columbia and the
Yukon Territory Frost has been praised
for exceptional situational awareness
being credited for his strengths and
planning and threat reaction in his
spare time she enjoys utilising your
training in mountain climbing
parachuting and diving frost is an
extremely focused individual who
meticulously plans out every move she
makes when she sits her eyes on a goal
there is little that can stop her she is
patient and never takes shortcuts for
others Frost's energy can be exhausting
reports consistently talk to Frost focus
and perseverance but this isn't to say
that she's overly hit strong interviews
any discriminated in a constructive
manner Frost is open and willing to take
on feedback the only area where resume
and can form it through individuals who
are a little less patient will prefer
taking short cuts Frost mission planning
is meticulous and this also carries over
to a personal life whether it be the
organization of an upcoming holiday or
the planning of appearance anniversary
party she is able to coordinate to the
finest details and ensure that
everything runs smoothly outside the
excitement of operations this sexually
seems to be what drives her in life
music relaxing this isn't really your
style
the only concern would be how does she
react when these high-level plans don't
go as expected such a situation is
listed in her medical records though the
report doesn't go into much detail it
revolves around a hunting trip in Canada
frost prefers not to discuss the
incident but it has something to do with
their being forced to make an emergency
landing in her plane it's clear she
blames herself for not being prepared
for such an incident frost has developed
a strong friendship with specialist
nomads both women have a strong
connection with the outdoors and she has
similar life experiences Frost's
precision or intended personality is a
huge asset but until she was able to
observe her own mental and emotional
processes she is at risk of clashing
with stronger personalities within the
group with the background of mechanical
engineering frost helped design and
modify a mechanical trap that is able to
incapacitate enemies the sterling mark -
otherwise known as the welcome mat is a
floor mounted rubber and metallic
spring-loaded leg hold trap this
non-lethal trap is designed to allow for
seamless deployment without extensive
camouflage the completely non mechanical
device is unable to be detected by
electronic scanners
tydomin
sebastian cote codenamed buck as an
attacking operator and team rainbow buck
comes from a long line of military
veterans while attending university who
served in the canadian reserves and
after graduating with a degree in
criminology he enlisted full-time and
the canadian armed forces assigned to
the military police he specialized in
high-risk situations long and close
range marine rescue and armed ship
boarding this made him a strong
candidate for the emergency response
team and eventually the jtf2 he was
raised with tales of his Voyager
ancestors who pedaled the rivers across
Canada worked as fur trappers and helped
map the north for the railroad and
mining industries but grew up in a
close-knit family and is the middle of
three his family is very physically
active and most of the ventures are
centered around the outdoors recently he
discovered his great-grandfather at
almost drowned in some Rapids and if it
had not been for the determination and
quick thinking of his friend from one of
the Mohawk tribes who would have drowned
buck reflects that if it hadn't been for
this man his father had never be born
fluid in French English and pasture he
is also currently enrolled in Mohawk
studies where he hopes to learn more
about the Mohawk people and if he can
help give back in some way and this
pretty much sums buck up though he is
eager to make a difference in the world
his approach is sensible and realistic
he works towards actual results and the
effort required doesn't deter her
while a part of the world-renowned
Canadian Special Forces buckers
continued to hone his skills and
high-speed technical driving on land and
water hazardous materials management and
hostage rescue as expected this line of
work brings a fair amount of stress but
buck exhibits tremendous amounts of
self-discipline and adaptive thinking
and doesn't seem to have a problem
overcoming this highly pragmatic buck
will always take the shortest distance
between two points he is not one to
mince words or exaggerate he enjoys
simple mechanical devices rather than
the more high-tech arsenal employed by
other members of Team rainbow buck is
one of those easygoing people who can
settle into any conversation his
attitude towards others making one of
the more flexible members of the team he
is laid-back he is able to maintain a
professional demeanor in the field this
ability to work with any crowd was
appreciated but everyone who works
alongside him although buck is a veteran
of the forces his adventurous spirits
allows them to approach all missions
with a kind of fresh enthusiasm Buck's
gadget is an under barrel shotgun
attachment on his main weapon the SK
4:12 otherwise known as the skeleton key
is an under barrel mounted 12-gauge
shotgun by changing camp positions on
his assault rifle he is able to quickly
switch from ranged to close quarter
combat the skeleton key is also an
effective breaching tool to destroy
barricades or create a line of sight
overall these videos on the story behind
these operators there's been a few that
have really stuck out to me some of
their personalities and the struggles
they go through so similar to people I
know obviously the people I know aren't
counter-terrorists or special forces but
they have similar backgrounds and issues
they've had to face in their lives now
there are any operator stories that you
can relate to or that remind you of
people in your life I really must
apologize to the more consistent viewers
of the channel for the large gap in my
uploads recently since the lockdown has
been lifted in New Zealand I've been
super busy at work plus we're actually
looking to move house in the next little
while so there's a lot of organization
around that sort of stuff otherwise
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one hopefully
a little sooner than this one took me to
make juice